lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
tratar de entender como dos proteínas
pueden interactuar entre sí
junto con el atp para generar movimiento
mecánico y la razón por la que quiero
hacerlo es porque aunque sucede fuera de
las células musculares
este será realmente el primer vídeo
sobre cómo funcionan los músculos y
después hablaremos sobre cómo los
nervios estimulan a los músculos para
que funcionen y todo esto lo haremos a
partir de este vídeo lo que hice fue
copiar y pegar dos imágenes de proteínas
de wikipedia
esta es la miosina en realidad es mi
oficina tipo 2 porque tiene dos cadenas
de proteína que están entrelazadas una
con otra y como pueden ver es una
proteína o enzima muy compleja pero vale
la pena estudiarla les diré por qué se
llama enzima porque en realidad ayuda a
que el atp se convierta en a bp y en
grupos fosfatos por eso se le llama una
atp esa es una subclase de las enzimas
atp asas
esta es la actina veremos en este vídeo
como la miosina utiliza el atp para
arrastrarse por la actina que podríamos
ver como una cuerda y esto es lo que
genera energía mecánica lo dibujaré lo
dibujaré sobre esta activa que tenemos
aquí digamos que tenemos una de estas
cabezas de miosina cuando me refiero a
una cabeza de miosina me refiero a esta
parte de aquí que está conectada
enrollada alrededor de esta otra
consideremos solo una de estas cabezas
de miosina digamos que tiene esta
posición
veamos cómo puedo dibujarla supongamos
que al principio tiene esta posición y
esta parte de aquí es como una cola que
está conectada a otra estructura y
hablaremos con detalle sobre esto aquí
está mi cabeza de miosina en su posición
inicial sin hacer nada ahora llega el
atp y se enlaza con esta cabeza de
miosina esta enzima esta proteína esta
enzima
les dibujaré unos atp digamos que viene
el atp y se enlaza con esta de aquí en
realidad no es así de grande comparado a
la proteína pero es solo para darles una
idea tan pronto como se une el atp al
lugar apropiado en la enzima o proteína
la enzima se separa de la actina lo
escribiré aquí uno el atp se une a la
cabeza de miosina e inmediatamente esto
causa que la miosina se separe de la
actina
ese es el primer paso al empezar la
miosina está pegada a la actina y luego
viene el atp y se separan en el
siguiente paso se verá algo así quiero
dibujarla en el mismo lugar en el
siguiente paso se habrá separado de la
actina y ahora luce algo así con el atp
todavía unido a ella sé que se ve un
poco complicado porque estoy dibujando
una cosa arriba de la otra pero noten
que el atp está unido a y en el
siguiente paso el atp se hidroliza y el
fosfato se desprende de él
esta es una enzima atp esa es lo que
hace déjenme escribirlo paso 2 el atp se
convierte en a bp más un grupo fosfato y
esto libera energía para cargar esta
proteína miosina y dejarla en una clase
de estado de alta energía hagamos el
segundo paso esto se hidroliza libera
energía sabemos que la atp es la unidad
biológica de energía así que el atp
libera energía
lo estoy dibujando como si fuera una
pequeña chispa o explosión pero
imagínense que está cambiando la
conformación de esta proteína como en
una especie de resorte a presión para
que luego pueda arrastrarse a lo largo
de la actina así que en el segundo paso
más energía y digamos que carga de
energía a la proteína o enzima y cambia
su conformación imaginen que es como si
estuviera contrayendo un resorte y
energizando lo la conformación de la
proteína se refiere a su forma segundo
paso lo que ocurre es que el grupo
fosfato que todavía estaba unido ahora
se separa del resto del atp y entonces
este último se convierte en a bp y la
energía que se libera cambia la
conformación de la proteína que ahora
toma esta posición déjenme dibujarlo
aquí al final del segundo paso las cosas
se ven así quiero asegurarme de que lo
estoy mostrando bien al final del
segundo paso la proteína se ve como algo
así
está en un estado cargado en este
momento tiene mucha energía en esta
posición es como un resorte apretado
todavía está en la dp ahí está la
adenosina y los dos grupos fosfatos en
el atp y ahí está el otro grupo fosfato
ahora cuando ese grupo fosfato se libera
es el tercer paso acuérdense cuando
empezamos esto estaba aquí y el atp se
le unió al fin del primer paso lo que
hizo que la miosina se separara después
del primer paso obviamente viene el
segundo el atp se hidroliza
convirtiéndose en a bp y fosfato esto
libera energía lo cual deja a la miosina
en esta posición de alta energía
conectada al siguiente escalón del
filamento de actina ahora estamos en un
estado de alta energía déjenme
escribirlo en el tercer paso el fosfato
se separa de la miosina el fosfato se
separa de la miosina en el tercer paso
eso que se está separando es un grupo
fosfato y lo que esto hace es liberar la
energía de esta posición de alta carga
y esto causa que la miosina empuje a la
actina es como si fuera el movimiento de
un pistón en un motor de auto esto es lo
que genera el movimiento mecánico de
modo que cuando el grupo fosfato se
separa realmente recuerda la separación
original es cuando el atp se convierte
en a bp y un fosfato cuando el fosfato
se separa la miosina se descarga se
libera como un resorte y esto hace que
empuje el filamento de actina así que
puedes ver esto como un golpe de poder
en realidad se está generando energía
mecánica
así que si consideras que es la actina
la que está fija cualquier cosa que esté
unido a la miosina se movería a la
izquierda sí imaginen que la miosina es
la que está fija la actina y todo lo que
esté unido a ella se moverá a la derecha
se puede ver de ambas formas es así que
se produce la acción muscular y después
viene el cuarto paso en la dps se
separan y entonces todo vuelve a estar
igual que antes del primer paso excepto
que ahora estamos un peldaño más a la
izquierda de la mole
de actina para mí todo esto es muy
impresionante podemos ver cómo se
utiliza la energía de la atp
vemos que la energía química o la
energía de enlace del atp se transforma
en energía mecánica para mí es
impresionante porque cuando aprendí por
primera vez sobre el atp todos decían
que el atp se usa para todo tipo de
procesos celulares y para contraer los
músculos y yo pensaba bueno pero como es
que la energía de enlace lleva a la
contracción muscular y a su vez toda la
energía mecánica que vemos en nuestra
vida cotidiana y es aquí donde todo esto
sucede por eso todo esto funciona así y
uno piensa cómo es que estas cosas
cambian de forma recuerden que estas
proteínas cambian de conformación con
base en lo que se une o se separa de
ellas y para lograr algunas de estas con
formaciones se necesita más energía y
gracias a ciertos procesos esa energía
se puede liberar para empujar otra
proteína yo lo encuentro fascinante y
ahora que sabemos sobre las
interacciones
cocina y la actina podremos entender
cómo funcionan realmente los músculos